l'un des principaux enjeux à vue en
cours sera l'ancienne friche thales
comment ce secteur va être réaménagé
cette zone implanté entre l'avenue léon
blum et celle de l'europe devrait
accueillir d'ici 2030 plus de 1300
logements des commerces des activités
économiques des espaces verts des
services publics sur plus de 22 hectares
le site qui sera baptisé le quartier des
savoirs va également accueillir la
future station de métro saint quentin
est du grand paris express en super
métro reliant orly à versailles en 30
minutes
avec ce nouveau quartier le nombre de
guyancourt toit devrait passer de 29
mille à trente deux mille habitants
les logements justement seront un
deuxième enjeu à guyancourt la ville
compte actuellement près de 48 % de
logements sociaux 18% de plus que la
moyenne des communes voisines
faut-il aller plus loin ou réduire ce
chiffre d'autre part la ville a entamé
depuis quelques années une
reconfiguration de ses quartiers
notamment des transformations dans le
quartier du pont du rotois depuis 2006
l'un des plus vieux quartiers de la
ville créée en 1974
enfin les entreprises seront également
un enjeu la ville compte à ce jour 2536
firme sur son territoire presque 1000 de
plus qu'en 2012 parmi elles des grosses
entreprises comme sodexo le groupe à ce
mode est spécialisé dans les jeux de
société ou encore le technocentre
renault qui emploie près de 9500
personnes la ville doit-elle accueillir
plus entreprises